maybe I'll find it in the middle yo yo
he won't find it in the middle that's it
she's crying
we're going to be swapping Filipino and
American snacks I'm from the Philippines
it's my first time eating American food
I am American and it is definitely my
first time trying a Filipino snacks I
don't know if I've had American snacks
boy I don't know if I've had Filipino
snacks before I send up that at home
I'm originally from North Carolina I
know no it's my first time in the
Fayetteville newbie from like the south
this is a durian candy where I'm from
this is like this is what most people
eat but not a lot of people like it like
my family eats it but I don't like it
personally so Abel one of my favorite
what's the flavor I can durian okay you
know durian I know what durian is but
I've never had it a little bit it does
stink kind of how is it not good I don't
it's like marshmallow and then there's
like another solid mass inside that
right yeah it has like a tacky flavor
it definitely melts in your mouth so
these are different variations of the
cheese Cheetos a little hotter as you
can tell by the many flames I like them
but I'm kind of a baby and I can't
handle this by some time so this is a
large bag I'll eat half of like a snack
sized bag and that's pretty much as much
as I can take down the edge yeah
it's really good I like spicy but oh my
god this is so good
tastes kind of sorry they're not that
hot no no they're not that hot but but
they like if you eat a lot
oh I can feel it if you eat a lot that's
gonna burn the top foods to put my time
it's really hot my thumb is like it's
burning right now mm-hmm
but I like it I like to paint it's
working a little bit I like it
this is a Chapman this is like chocolate
and peanuts combined together it's a
pack of gum almost Oh
mm-hmm that's interesting there's not
peanuts on the inside they just infused
as a flavor inside the chocolate
Twizzlers there yeah one of my favorite
movie theater snacks when we did really
well on tests my teachers would give
these out and the smaller packages gonna
smell psycho
bubble gum we used to have like sword
fights when I was a kid it's not give me
give me it's drink so it's like an
eraser
get you more of them that's a problem
you gotta eat like at least half of
these and then you're gonna get that
flavor of strawberry you like it bad
all right kids look like snacks you know
that you drizzle sugar in it or
something and this just really was just
rubber to me I don't think a offense to
it because it is a very strange texture
that I feel like you had to kind of get
used to this is my favorite actually
from my hometown it's um dried mangoes
with salmon oh that sounds good oh my
god oh okay you're welcome
there's like dried mangoes coated in
sugar all right taste of turmeric mmm I
don't taste the tamarind but it's softer
than the regular dried mangoes that's so
good thank you
Twinkies are such a classic indulgent
American snack
this is definitely a fair type of food
you see this at the gas station for
really cheap kind of looks like loaf
bread with some vanilla inside I don't
think I've ever smelled it very good
it's very good I like it so it's a
vanilla cream on the inside and then a
spongy cake on the outside I like more
yeah the combo is good
rescueteers this is like a childhood
snack there's a specific way of eating
this so I want to know if you know how
to hit it with my mouth a thinner than I
expected kids do it like this all right
well I'm doing it the way the kids do it
I can actually finish like a whole bug
by myself or watching movies it's like
playing but like you just can't get
enough yeah these are great and they're
fun we should have more interactive
snack foods in America I think it's
important to try other cultures snacks
just because it why didn't your horizon
for your taste buds and it's important
to try those yeah I was surprised that I
would like these American foods I mean
I'm a picky eater so I loved it if you
have the resources to try some snacks
that you can only find in different
countries just to maybe give you a
little bit more perspective and here
someone else tried snacks and you grew
up with I was certainly very surprised
by your reaction to Twizzlers
it's very funny so I think that was
pretty entertaining this at least
[Music]
[Music]